Film Courage: Dialogue is not conversation?
Scott Myers, DePaul University Professor/Screenwriter/Creator
Gointothestory.blcklst(dot)com: It’s conversation
with a purpose.
It’s people conversing but every line needs
to move the story forward in some respect,
whether it’s moving the plot forward through
some sort of revelation that a character makes
or moves these characters forward in their
own relationship because they have an argument
and that conflict causes one or both of them
or more of them to shift in terms of their
thought processes and feelings or it provides
some exposition, some information, some data
which is a key to help them get a clue to
move the thing forward.
But yes dialogue is conversation but it’s
conversation with a purpose.
You need to be really mindful of that.
So that’s tricky because it’s got to be
entertaining too.
And in an ideal world it’s more often then
not it’s subtextual so that what is being
communicated is really more about what is
underneath the words than the words themselves.
It’s also dialogue is also the words that
aren’t spoken.
Sometimes the best dialogue is what is not
said.
So I get the message, is dialogue conversation
and the subtext there is don’t make it just
like how people talk in real life like because
we just blabber on and on.
We don’t have that amount of time in a screenplay.
You need to be precise and efficient.
But yes it is conversational.
It should sound conversational like how characters
would talk in the real world.
So I get it but it’s conversation with a
purpose.
That would be my take on that.
Film Courage: Are there any films that are
a great study in subtext?
Scott: I would say read anything by Tony Girl
like MICHAEL CLAYTON, that script.
He’s just an amazing writer and MICHAEL
CLAYTON is a script that just anybody should
read because he not only has subtext going
on but the text is so entertaining and there
is layers to it so sometimes he’s saying
what is absolutely on the character’s mind
so the text is like right there and the meaning
of the words are right up top but then there
are other layers underneath too.
So he is really brilliant and MICHAEL CLAYTON
is a script I absolutely recommend.